je ne sors pas je ne peux pas sortir
parce que je suis au quatrième étage
descendre et remonter si c'est un combat
aujourd'hui
[Musique]
je pourrais pas imaginer que l'enfant ci
prévoit d'aider ces gens des situations
déjà qu'on suive entre ici la cheville
avait l'ascenseur et emplissent si je
voyais encore et pendant qu'ils aient
suite d'événements non voyantes
c'est là où il ya plus d'ascenseur c'est
beaucoup plus grave
[Musique]
franchement j'aime histoire des mines et
gémissant délaissé abandonné
c'est ça que j'aimais ça abandonnée
délaissé des mini c'est que c'est une
prison qui j'ai vu la porte est fermée
j'arrive pas à descendre mais pendant
l'été imaginez-vous jeu puis prendre des
lettres d or mais j'ai pu pas j'ai une
besoin d'aller prendre des délais et je
ne paie pas
[Musique]
ah ah
si je peux même changé j'aimerais bien
pour changer pour sortir un peu et est
délivrée de cette prison pour changer un
peu de vie déjà de venir et non voyantes
je peux dire c'est grave pour moi est en
10e et être en prison